we begin with this for the first time
Republican Senate Leader Mitch McConnell
is suggesting he's open to new laws
requiring background checks on all gun
buyers this comes in the aftermath of
the deadly El Paso and Dayton shootings
McConnell says gun control legislation
will be considered next month after the
Senate's August recess Democratic House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi asked President
Trump yesterday to use his
constitutional authority to force the
Senate back into session immediately Ben
Tracy is at the White House Ben what's
the likelihood that the president would
do that not very likely and because
right now there is not bipartisan
legislation on the hill that could
actually quickly pass but White House
officials do say the president is
serious about doing something on gun
control but he's now getting pushback
from the NRA public pressure for gun
control legislation is not letting up on
Thursday it could be seen in Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell's
hometown McConnell says he will not be
intimidated by protests but in a rare
move did say he is open to background
check legislation let me get back
hopefully be able to come together and
actually pass something on Wednesday
when President Trump visited the cities
reeling from the nation's latest mass
shootings he also spoke on the phone
several times with Wayne LaPierre the
head of the National Rifle Association
the NRA does not seem to like what the
president has been saying I'm looking to
do background checks I think background
checks are important in a statement
Thursday Lapierre said the NRA opposes
any legislation that unfairly infringes
upon the rights of law-abiding citizens
and called gun control proposals
currently being floated soundbite
solutions safer you are so afraid of the
NRA the president has sometimes chided
his own party about their loyalty to the
NRA then our with you we have to fight
him everyone said oh that's okay after
the parklands shooting the president
promised tougher background checks but
then sided with the NRA
promised to defend the Second Amendment
rights of every American and I always
will I'll never let you down the
president doesn't want to risk upsetting
his base before the election but a
senior administration official says that
mr. Trump realizes he needs to back some
form of gun control even if the NRA is
not on board on Thursday the President
did talk to two top Democrats Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer they say that
he assured them he will review any
bipartisan legislation tarika Ben thank
you